In Germany, officials say a suspected right-wing extremist killed himself...
...after going on a shooting rampage in two shisha bars,...
...killing nine people including migrants from Turkey.
In South Korea, the first death has been recorded in the country...
...of a person infected with the coronavirus,...
...as those infected rise by 104, making a total of 75,730 cases worldwide.
In Australia, a local report states...
...that ex-rugby player Rowan Baxter committed suicide in Brisbane...
...after allegedly killing his wife and three children by dousing them with gasoline...
...and setting them on fire in their family car.
Police in Zambia arrested 16 people suspected of being behind chemical attacks...
...that have been happening since December,...
...where people have been sprayed with poisonous substances and some have died.
Finally from Saudi Arabia, Secretary of State Mike Pompeo...
...met with Saudi King Salman bin Abdulaziz al Saud and Crown Prince Mohammed bin Salman...
...to discuss the mutual threat and security concerns about Iran.
Pompeo also met with U.S. troops stationed in Saudi Arabia.